like we'll come on in okay you will see
an orange chair that is for you how they
both look are color - this is red that
has a little larger all right thank you
Michael welcome to the show this is a
great highlight for me to have you here
I really appreciate that
Birdman I've heard described and I would
even describe it it's almost like you as
cast members are dancing with the camera
in so many ways because there's so much
interesting movement can you recall
another movie that you've made that had
to be this precise no no nothing even
close in fact I don't think you can well
I know you can't make this movie
other than the way Alejandro laid it out
which was a long the longest rehearsal
period it was four weeks and it may have
been five I can't remember it had to be
choreographed down to sometimes
literally inches and we didn't have
access to the theater so what they did
was they went and they literally started
measuring the movements they said they
got a couple of actors to walk through
the scenes how old pages and there's a
dialogue through the scenes and they
would measure whether it was a tape how
far they would go before they had a turn
a corner and say certain lines sometimes
write on a word not just a line a word
when you made a corner because that
would cue a me or or or aundrea or Zach
or someone or or even a prop you know or
or light had to be physically moved so
it required that kind of a technical
rehearsal but also a lot of acting
rehearsal and it varies it varies and
there was no other way to do it he
didn't have the luxury we also shot it
in a short amount of time so
unbelievable well all the hard work paid
off because it's just has this
incredible unique feel to it unlike
anything I think anyone has ever seen
which is really cool yeah is there a
moment that you can think back to a
person or an experience that really
sticks out for you is teaching you that
you could do something important with
your work I went to a Catholic school in
grade school and I was really shy
actually I would get red in the face at
the
at any kind of attention that came my
way but I was pretty funny so sometimes
things would come my way all right like
I wasn't looking for it so one time I'd
done something I don't really remember
what it was but I was asked to stand and
it was a situation where I think she
said do you think that's funny or
something and actually I did think was
because it was fake right the feeling so
she goes why don't she sing us a song
and I remember even as a little kid and
I was probably only seven or eight and I
thought oh I see what this is this is
some kind of like shame deal this is
some kind of deal where you're supposed
to make me feel less and I'm gonna
buckle yeah and I remember thinking you
can either kind of wine and put your
head down and sit down or you can sing
and I said okay I'm a singer and I sang
full-out what you saying I can't
remember I just committed so much to
singing horribly and it was really a
great moment for me and I didn't even
realize there's a great moment for me
because I realized I either you know eat
those are times we either go down or you
it was only like a seven-year-old kid so
what did the sister do when you started
singing I remember her kind of getting
this kind of like a little little grin
on her face and it was a horrible
rendition of whatever I say the other
thing that we do on this show is we look
at one scene from your movie and we will
watch it together with these remote
controls in our hands and dissect it so
this is a scene from Berlin that you and
I both love it's a really great personal
moment between you and Amy Ryan who
plays your ex-wife right this comes near
the end of the film when you've really
been through an emotional rollercoaster
your character riggan a former action
star is now trying to write and direct
and star in a very intimate Broadway
play he's right that area where he's so
crazy he's about to break through to a
kind of clarity yeah as we will see so
let's take a look at a scene from
bourbon
I love Sam I know now instantly I'm
stopping here because you instantly
notice the intimacy between these two
yeah people yeah and is that really a
result of the incredible rehearsal
period that you guys were able to have I
think it comes from just going down
getting down to your basics and you know
not being afraid and telling the truth
I'd say that maybe too much rehearsal
would get in the way of a scene that's
for me well well the power is there
let's keep watching
I really wish I was the videotaped her
person why guys - miss the moment I
don't have it I should've just been
there - yeah you know just the regret
yeah that he's living with is so
palpable here is it not yeah and I think
if there was an award for Best
Performance by a tear in a supporting
role it would be this year that comes
down your nose it's so magical in a way
and do it I can call up one or seven
minutes I just asked the director how
many do you want
yeah like that happen on every tape yeah
that's the thing because you actually
that's not what you want to do in a way
you kind of don't want to go there if
you don't have to you know because it
can be very gushy you know there's
nothing gushy about that no that's one
perfect all right let's keep going
that's one thing I think this movie does
really well is talk about the sacrifices
of having a creative yeah life you can
certainly relate to missing out on
things and families members lives well
here's what's interesting
I actually don't because I turn I've
turned pheromone movies done with my son
was growing up cuz I I prefer being a
father it's just oh it's a selfish thing
I really liked it so I didn't want to
not be around and also I felt that it
was my job to be around since I wasn't
together with his mom you know my job
was to be the dad one
and her job was to be the mom so so I
don't I was around for about everything
and by the way that's no sacrifice you
know that's that's it it's being a dad
yeah yeah it's been supposed to do
there's a great moment coming up here
she's just gone oh I get it I understand
it was she knew dad she said she got
this guy who was a three-day viral
sensation it is so pathetic you know
come on there are more pathetic things
than back yeah I'm like a mustache what
a well-placed moment of humor she's so
great I mean I could act with her all
day long Oh ever since I saw her screen
I said wow that I just she's just kind
of honest and present you know and
truthfully you know the reason I like
this that one type of the scene is it's
it's tempting in a movie like this
probably to show something flashy I'm in
it
this is kind of an in this movie is so
good and I will say this unabashedly on
so many levels and there's so much
craziness to it and there's so much
high-pitched kind of mania mania exactly
that I I wanted to kind of I think
sometimes people don't talk about a
scene like this which is just really
simple and really human and really
honest
well the manic scenes have more power
because of the quieter scenes and
vice-versa
it all fits in together in a fascinating
way yet all right here's the end last
chance for places you better get back to
Z I mean do you think you'll ever have
an experience like this again is this
something that you'll strive for to do
something like this probably not to be
honest but but I don't know that I'll
ever get to play as many things
sometimes not only within one scene but
within one minute and one scene you know
I mean it there just aren't roles like
that I'm not sure there will be a role
like that for anybody I'm just really
glad the stars aligned and you were able
to get together with this care
at this point in your yes you rise to
the occasion beautifully well thank you
many congratulations thanks if you have
not seen Birdman be sure to check it out
so you can see Michael's fantastic
performance and thanks so much for
watching
Fandango frontrunners - thank you for
being here we've made you your own Regan
Thompson
Fandango gift card I really appreciate
the time view all right let's get our
photo tape right man followed out here
yet don't hit your head
I won't three two one all right great
daddy thank you thank you very much what
thank you